gun laws of course are different in
every state and with all the shootings
all across the country and the different
circumstances of each we did want to
take a step back and try to assess some
of the numbers with you so take a listen
to this there are nearly 434 million
firearms in civilian possession
Nationwide your friends your neighbors
your fellow Americans according to a
firearm industry trade Association and
what that means is that there are
roughly 100 million more guns in the
country than there are people in the
country now as far as the three states
that Mark Strassman just mentioned
Alabama and Missouri they've got the
fourth and Ninth highest firearm
mortality rates in the country while
Texas is 27th on that list about middle
of the pack it has the distinction of
having the highest total number of
firearm fatalities more than 4 600 a
year in all three of those states by the
way no permit is required to purchase a
rifle to purchase a shotgun or to
purchase a handgun